what's the next piece of advice we have
yeah so that actually that fits really
nicely with the next topic of small team
communication so how do you you know
while being transparent but as your team
grows how do you stay on the same page
with your team as I gross when you say
small team communication what size are
we talking about here what's a small
team in this definition for our
discussion purposes we would say under
10 10 or under so this is you got
friends and family seed funding maybe
you got your product coming to market or
maybe a little bit of traction
yeah maybe a bootstrapping move trapping
that's another possibility great you
really want to make sure you have your
communication streamlined and one way to
do this and keep everyone on the same
page is through setting something like a
12-week plan so this would include your
different revenue goals you know maybe
you could set those milestones at weekly
your hiring plans you know maybe you
have a specific you know conversion that
you're going for in an you know in your
email outreach so make sure you have
this plan and then set weekly touch
bases so for example you know we know
here at launch we do two lunches where
we all talk about okay what are the
overarching goals where are we tracking
against those plans and then you know we
also have our end of day reports which
we do um so we have everyone on the team
that is not on the in the fantastic for
the leadership team yep
the leadership team everyone sends an
update at the end of the day with
between four you know maybe four to ten
bullet points with links to everything
that they got done today
and it gives the team a you know this
this opportunity to you know brag a
little bit about what they got done and
you know things that they're proud of
that they did and how they're tracking
against the 12-week plan it also informs
the heck out of other people from other
departments we have whatever 14 or 15
people here so we're kind of just out of
small team and just starting to go into
a mid-size team and boy does that help
because sometimes I'm on the road or you
were just on the road in our Toronto
office and I'm sure being able to take
your phone out or at the end of the day
just be able to see what's going on out
here
versus in Toronto and see the bullet
points also reminds people back to that
repeating if you are sending that a OD
report just a five minute email at the
end of the day that just says here's the
top two or three things I got done you
can link to hey here's where the forum
is
here's the sales here's the Google
Analytics page here's the asana board
that we're working off of so I really
find the people who make plans and then
track themselves against them do better
and this is just if you can measure it
you can manage it or measure what
matters we have a lot of different
buzzwords for here in Silicon Valley but
plant a flag and see if you can hit it
be ambitious it's okay not to hit it but
better to make a plan not succeed and
learn something than to have no plan and
just be flying the plane out into the
great wide open like you don't know
where you're going you'd be going into a
thunderstorm you could be going into a
tornado you may not have enough fuel to
get you where you need to go and that's
what this planning I think can do for
yourself I would add to on the the end
of day end of week is it also from a
communication perspective it it cuts
down on excess communication I mean
you're putting everything in this
document daily or weekly and then your
manager or your boss doesn't have as
many questions for you later there's not
a lot there's not as much follow-up it's
it's been hugely helpful for our team
and I've heard feedback from a lot of
other teams actually that that have
implemented it and implementing it push
marketplace one of our investments read
my blog post about it just the EOD and
EOW reports and they said it's changed
everything for them so that's great and
what happens if people's VOD is light
and it doesn't look like their GSD
getting stuff done what do you what
happens then Sam yeah well ideally they
would come to us first and just say you
know before they even send it just say
hey I you know I don't feel like I have
enough to contribute in this EOD I don't
have enough to write down maybe I spent
too much you know looking at the news or
whatever and so not the job yeah yeah
reacting to emails coming in is not
exactly the job yeah so what we do in
that case is just you know evaluate the
role and what what that team member is
you know supposed to be taking ownership
of and you know give them more work if
necessary or or what I like to do is ask
them okay so you know this these are
your goals this is our 12-week plan how
can you contribute more for the team and
and what what could your EO DS look like
what would else can you accomplish this
is something that happens in companies
that people forget some
time you know after you have seven eight
nine people somebody winds up not
pulling their weight maybe because
they're lazy but more often than not
they just haven't been given a clear
path to contribute to the team so they
don't actually know what they're
supposed to be doing and you will have
this happen multiple times where the
team grows you add a bunch of people
people start specializing in different
verticals and then a person who was kind
of running around just putting out fires
in your small little five person startup
has nothing to do and when I came up in
the industry in the 90s there were
always people had their offices and like
the senior execs would be in their
offices and because I was an IT guy like
I could tell like their computers were
not being used or whatever what was
going on on their computers because we
had like a server architecture and like
I just remember one time this attorney
was just playing chess all day in his
room because he had chess master two
that he asked me to put chess master on
his computer I put it on there but I
could tell that chess master was on his
screen and he was using it all day it
was like wow this person is working at a
giant he's got persons getting paid six
figures to play chess for four hours a
day like they literally had nothing to
do and you really don't want that in
your company let's keep going here
so Charles makes the nice points here
our director by the way he started
interrupts he he said he uses his Odie
as a starting point as it to-do list in
the morning so we have seen that
phenomenon where people get into work
create a blank email to their team that
says things I got things I'm going to do
today and they write down a list of what
they're going to do and then check it
off as they go but we found these to be
super lightweight lightweight it's
important because you don't want people
spending two hours at the end of their
day reporting on what they did for 25%
of the time keep it to five or ten
minutes okay
any other points on that yeah and you
know a couple weeks ago just thinking
about the Odie's I had approached you
about hiring for a specific position
yeah you came back to me with the idea
well how about you know moving forward
whenever we want to hire a new person a
new team member you write down what
their yo DS would look like for a week
yeah and so what that enabled me to do
is sit down really think through okay
what am I looking for and I was also
able to utilize that when I was writing
the job description that I posted yeah
so I was able to just take that
information you know put that in the
LinkedIn yeah profile and it was you
know pretty much
cuz we're hiring for an analyst that
would be somebody at a venture firm who
just as the frontline of reviewing
companies that come in or companies we
find and trying to write some coverage
on them write a one or two page document
so the EOD for that person would say
reviewed fifteen applications for
funding you know to launch and wrote up
these three companies and set up
meetings with these four companies for
tomorrow to talk to them and evaluate
their startups and you could also look
at hey if you're eliminating a position
or merging positions you could just say
well if we have these two people working
right now maybe we need to consolidate
those positions because two peoples look
a little bit light or we're gonna
outsource something so if you see in the
same persons you know yo D report that
they're doing SDR work you know sales
development work for two or three hours
a day maybe say you know what let's get
that off their plate and give that to an
outsource company so it just gives you
an idea of what the actual work getting
done is obviously our last point here
you use lightweight communications
fairly obvious anything to add to that
yeah we we here at slack used or at
launch you slacks are yeah and you know
I'm hoping it's like they used chat
previously it was emailed I think since
we've moved a slack it enables you to so
there can be some negative so you know
slot can get distracting but if you keep
everyone focused and you have specific
purposes for your channels it keeps
everything very streamlined and it keeps
it a lot lighter and less formal than
say an email would be so you know you
can so you have a question you could
just slack it over to actually versus
having to you know open up an email talk
about an email include the contacts
things like that yeah if you're a
developer or you're a writer slack is
death because it takes you out of your
flow of writing so when I'm writing the
first thing I do is turn off all my
slack channels and I just use a Google
Doc and I turn off every other window
because it's just distracting but for
everybody else if you're running around
and you're part of the sales team and
the marketing team yeah it's kind of
like a back and forth your volleying a
whole bunch with your and having the
rooms there it makes it super easy and
lightweight I just think I love most is
how we pull data in and I think we're
going to talk about that later but
putting in the report
data feeds into your slack makes it
super interesting just like the EOD
reports do it just kind of keeps you
informed as to the lifeblood of the
company I've told you this over and over
again Zendesk is the best customer
support system in the world and they
have a range of products now with the
Zendesk suite from live chat to a
knowledgebase
tons of features for you to get all of
your communication in one place with
your valuable customers and make sure
that none of these important discussions
with your customers go into the black
hole or get lost
think about what happens your customers
have a need they go to your help desk
they start chatting with an agent you
don't want to lose this moment in which
you can shine and show how much you love
and care about your customers if you
love and care about your customers
you're gonna want to use the Zendesk
suite you know all that integrated
customer support you get a call center
you get the knowledgebase live chat all
that stuff and it's gonna work
brilliantly so all the data gets shared
back with the rest of your organization
whether the people in finance or product
development or the c-suite want to know
what's going on and what's going on on
the frontline when your customers are
actually engaging with your products
well all that information is gonna be in
one place organized right and Zen desks
knows that you're going to love it as
much as their customers Hallet on slack
air B&B allah tote all of these
customers are using Zen desk every day
these are the most successful customers
as well can you imagine your peloton
there's a lot of customer support I'm
sure when you're standing a physical
product with a subscription with
internet connections peloton uses it
slack one of the most important
companies of this generation of
companies uses it Airbnb the greatest
company never come out of Y Combinator
okay
qualifying startups are gonna get the
most amazing offer I think we've ever
had here on this week in startups in a
decade you're not gonna believe this
they want to give you a year free in
Zendesk by going to Zendesk calm such
twists if you're a startup and the
definition of startup I have to say it's
pretty generous a hundred employees or
less series beer or less okay terms and
conditions apply of course we get your
free full year right now Zendesk calm /
twist
Zendesk calm / twist well done Zendesk
well done